senator elizabeth warren is introducing
a brand new piece of legislation today
that is targeting cryptocurrency
exchanges and market participants she's
worried that russians or other people
who are on the sanction list may try to
use cryptocurrencies to actually evade
those sanctions now there's almost no
evidence whatsoever that anyone's doing
this or that it even would be possible
but she's worried so she's putting for
the legislation that legislation
promises to do three core things the
first is that it would grant the
treasury department the ability to
prohibit exchanges under us jurisdiction
from processing transactions involving
addresses affiliated with russians all
russians not just the ones on the
sanctioned list seems kind of crazy then
it would also give the president the
authority to apply secondary sanctions
to foreign exchanges that do business
with sanctioned people companies or
government entities and last but not
least it would require all u.s taxpayers
holding more than ten thousand dollars
worth of cryptocurrency offshore to
report those holdings so the treasury
department's financial crimes
enforcement network this makes almost no
sense
why are we making u.s citizens reveal
and give up their financial privacy
simply because we think maybe possibly
there might be a chance that somebody
would use cryptocurrencies to evade
sanctions well we go ahead and we look
at this quote from elizabeth warren she
said putin and his cronies can move
store and hide their wealth using
cryptocurrencies we can't allow them to
fund russia's war against ukraine and
evade our economic sanctions by using
crypto we haven't seen a single report
of anyone saying they're doing this we
haven't seen any exchange say that
they're going to allow them to do this
in fact every major crypto exchange said
that they're going to comply with the
sanctions if there's an individual who
has an account that's on the sanction
list and also has an account at the
crypto exchange the exchange will not
service them anymore they're preventing
any one of the only 25 000 different
wallet addresses that have been
identified they can't transact or send
money to or from those exchanges this is
what occurs when the crypto companies
explain they want to comply with the
rules they're enforcing the sanctions so
why we need to go an extra step for an
industry just the latest example of why
there's over regulation in this industry
if we then go ahead and we take a look
at what the treasury department's been
saying they said it will be extremely
challenging to evade our sanctions
without detection well there are some
deficient exchanges that may be willing
to offer services to sanction persons
and entities they will not be able to
support a large economy the treasury has
been significantly increasing its
ability to track virtual currency
transactions via partnerships across the
federal government and with the private
sector ultimately we're watching the
treasury department say we got this
we're watching we're paying attention we
have no signal whatsoever that anyone is
doing this and so lastly we have mike
novogratz billionaire crypto investor he
recently went on bloomberg and here's
what he had to say about this exact
situation if you were going to design
uh a trap to catch criminals it would
look a lot like the bitcoin blockchain
and so it's just elizabeth warren is
just wrong when she thinks you can use
uh bitcoin for russia to exceed
sanctions and we're looking at it the
wrong way the russian ruble has
depreciated over 90 percent in the last
10 years just this year alone i think
high to low is like 65
the turkish lira did the same
bitcoin is a lifeline to people in
countries with really poor stewardship
of their economy
and we should be thrilled that russians
can get some of their money in bitcoin
so they're not completely broke holding
worthless rubles now i tend to think
that mike novogratz absolutely nailed it
it would be nearly impossible for a
criminal to go
use bitcoin to do any sort of activity
and not get caught what we are watching
is a public ledger that is auditable by
anyone in the world it's immutable it
means it never will change people will
be able to go back 5 10 15 20 years from
now and still see every single
transaction and be able to publicly
audit it that doesn't sound like a
system a criminal wants to use and of
course bitcoin is that lifeline as mike
described bitcoin is providing an outlet
for people in ukraine russia and
elsewhere around the world anyone with
an internet connection can now store
their wealth in a digital location that
no one else can confiscate or censor
them and that's a really big idea it
sounds really important for literally
hundreds of millions of people globally
in this exact moment hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time